Our goal is to create a model to understand a phenomenon.
We cannot do this in isolation.
Modeling must be done in tandem with forming and
reforming questions, and validating the model that we create.
The process of model building in data analysis can be
thought of as occurring in three phases.
Questioning, modeling, and validating.
In the course of analysis we are constantly iterating back and
forth among these things in successive loops that build upon each other.
So it turns out that the single most frequent call to AT&T's helpline is,
when will my UVerse technician arrive.
And so AT&T thought it would be valuable to create a model for
performing this prediction.
So my modeling process began with a simple question.
When will my service tech arrive?
Now in order to make this question answerable, it has to be made quantitative.
And so we must choose a metric that captures this phenomenon